we can never have too much practice
getting familiar with the vectors and
what I want to do in this video is in
particular be able to relate the x and y
components of a vector to the initial
and terminal points to where we place it
in the coordinate plane so what am I
talking about so let's say we have some
vector where its initial point is here
so that's at Point a and it's terminal
point is I will do that in brown its
terminal point let's say is right over
here
let's call that point B and so the
vector is going to look like this and I
will do that I want to do it in the
color hole I'll do it in green so let me
see if I can draw all right so that's
what the vector is going to look like
that green is it super visible but I can
color it in a little bit better let me
color it in so you can really see it now
alright so that's what my vector looks
like it starts play based on where I've
placed it on the coordinate plane it has
an initial point at a and the terminal
point at B and what I want to do is if I
know the coordinates of a and B figure
out what the x and y components of my
vector let's just call this vector let's
call this vector V let's call that
vector V so what are the coordinates of
a so the coordinates of a the x
coordinate is negative 1 negative 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 so a is equal to negative 8
comma and the y coordinate is 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 so it's negative 8 comma 7 this is
negative 8 this is 7 and the point B the
terminal point of the vector that has
the coordinates let's see x equals 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 7 comma and then the y
coordinate is negative 1 negative 2 7
comma negative 2 so given that what are
going to be the x and y components of
our vector V well let's just think about
it so our vector V and there's multiple
ways that we've already seen that we can
the vector a one way is used the unit
vector notation where actually let me do
it that way first where this is whatever
is in parentheses is our is our X
component and then whatever is in these
parentheses is our Y component I'm just
multiplying I really I'm just killing up
the unit vector in the horizontal
direction and this and the unit vector
in the vertical direction and you could
look at the videos on unit vector
notation if this doesn't if this looks
foreign to us but let's figure out what
the X component is going to be well why
don't we to think about is you could
just view it as the change in X between
the initial point and the terminal point
so the change in X is going to be the
terminal x7 minus the initial X minus
negative 8 and our Y component we could
just view as the change in Y from the
initial point to the terminal point so
we finish at the terminal point so that
is negative 2 negative 2 minus minus our
initial Y minus 7 minus 7 and so what
does this give us well let me do all of
this so 7 minus negative 8 that's the
same thing as 7 plus 8 so or 7 plus plus
8 so that's going to be equal to 15 so
we get 15 times I 15 I'll do this part
in blue 15 I plus then I'll do this in
I'll do this in this move color negative
2 minus 7 that is negative 9 so I could
say plus negative 9 J or I could just
say minus 9 minus 9 j
that's one way to write our vector
that's one way to write our vector and
our other way is just to make sure we
remember there's just a bunch of
different notations that people use for
vectors you could write it like this you
could actually just use parentheses you
could just say it's 15 comma 9 15 comma
sorry not 15 comma 9 15 comma negative 9
15 comma negative 9 these are just
different representations of the same
vector you could even write it like this
vector V is equal to you can write it as
a column vector
you could write it as 15 15 negative 9
so depending on what book or notation
and what class you're in you might see
all of these things these are all the
same vectors that you know and love and
we can see that over here we can see
that over here 15 I 15 I is going to be
a vector that's 15 times bigger than the
unit vectors in the horizontal direction
so 1 whoops so let me draw that so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 so this
right over here is the vector 15 I so
let me draw that so that right over
there that is the vector 15 I and then
the vector negative 9j well it's gonna
go down 9 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so
negative 9 J is gonna look like this
negative 9 j- 9 J that's a little bit
hard to read let me trace that in black
negative negative 9 J and you see if you
take 15 I plus negative 9 J you're gonna
get 2 you're going to get our entire
vector V which is exactly what we wrote
here you could say the X component is 15
the Y component is negative 9 or another
way to say it if we're to go from point
A to B your change in X you increased 15
your change in Y well you decreased 9
and that tells you the x and y
components of the vector that starts
here and then moves there now this just
happens to be where we place this vector
as we know as we do different things
with vectors we might choose to shift
them around but the important thing is
that they keep the same magnitude and
direction